this is the news Chris Haynes uh says
the MRI revealed an injury to the
lateral meniscus embiid in consultation
with the Sixers medical staff and
several leading Specialists will be out
through the weekend while a treatment
plan is finalized and updates to be
provided wow as appropriate that is U
devastating yeah and so we see chuckster
the extent of that injury and how long
um you will be lost to the Phil felia
76ers you know miniscus are tricky I had
a meniscus one time and played in a
couple weeks and I've seen guys miss a
month or two so we got to wait and see
the results but it's a devastating
injury the
Sixers without
him they might be a lottery team that's
how great he is and um man I hope he's
not out of extended period of time
because uh it it it's just it's not
number one he's the MVP that's how great
a player he is but the Sixers got zero
chance without him zero 26 and8 this
year when he plays they are three and
nine when he doesn't I love the way he
was playing he's been in the groove all
year hopefully it's not as bad as what
has been
reported uh but I mean I I mean I feel
for the kid you know I've been watching
him play closely all year you know the
70 point game was phenomenal but the way
he's playing the way he's dominant the
way he's taking over the game
like he just had it and like I haven't
seen a guy play like that in a long time
you know from start to now he's just
been playing uh the clearcut MVP I know
he's close to like if he missed a couple
more games he'd be uh uh ineligible
exactly for that but listen the way this
guy was playing Keem malijan like you
know just dominating smooth you know his
his uh free throw line jumper was
automatic you know three-point ball was
automatic and you know hopefully it's
not that bad but if it is I I might have
to agree with Chuck I think especially
when you have to sit out for a long
period of time and then try to come back
and play at that same same level you
know it's going to be difficult but I
feel for the kid cuz he was he was a
clear-cut MVP for this year he's uh
missing his 13th game tonight at Utah
which is game two of our double header
and of course it has brought up this
conversation about uh qualif you know
qualifying for the regular season awards
in which you have to play 65 games so I
mean he's only got four other games left
that he could miss he's gon to miss more
than four games he's definitely goingon
to miss more than four games but let let
me answer that question these players
got nobody to blame but themselves The
Players Association signed off on the
deal I thought it should have been 70
games honestly personally rather than 65
yeah one than 65 but these guys have put
their self in a situation where they
didn't didn't respect the game and start
resting and and and load managing and
the NBA had to do something these fans
man they they get to see these guys one
time a year they're paying all these
money for tickets and these guys are
making 30 40 50 $60 million they need to
play it's unfortunate what happened to
him but I don't I hear all these guys
whining about well you know it's not
he's not fair he GNA play a bad rule
it's a bad rule it's a fair rule in my
opinion 65 games I told you I thought it
should have been 70 well I I don't I
think that um 65 games is a fair number
for for you know if there's close races
like Shaq and steveen NZ back in the day
and and and moving forward you know
there's been some close
races um it's not just a player sit out
thing it's an organizational thing
there's organizations that tell players
to sit out like no you're not playing
tonight we're we we you've hit your
maximum node for those who don't know
players wear uh devices on their uh in
on their practice jerseys which alerts
the medical staff when you hit a certain
number for your thresher which is from
your body weight your size and all these
kind of things the Met mechanical things
it initially was only from the
organization then the players started to
participate in it now saying no yeah I
do need it I do need that rest so it is
a combination of the two but winning an
award or winning in a championship are
two different things sh I I I would beg
the differ you'd rather win a
championship
and play 60 games yeah than when it's
MVP and play 65 but but I think it
should be certain amendments like
somebody fell on his knee it's not his
fault you don't have to miss 15 the way
he was playing that's not his fault like
I agree with Tru the low management the
oh my b no but if something like a freak
accident like that happened like the
year I got MVP I think I played six b
game but I came down on my knee one time
and busted the capsule and had to miss
four or five games so the amendment
should say something like that like if
you you have an injury caused by
somebody else the numbers don't count
because I know we're at 12 but that
wasn't his fault last night like a guy
fell on his knee so what about the first
eight yeah but but he's still at eight
so still got left
listen first I'm not going to go to war
as much as I love the players I'm not
going to go to war over individual
Awards because what does it stop if a
guy's playing greet and he plays 50
games did he get to get be MVP no he
shouldn't get to be MVP so we can haggle
over like keny said it and I said it
first obviously 65 is fair 65 out of 82
games that is
fair